but the focus of this administration on  vaccination  is uh mind-boggling listen in many cases  they've done a very good job  getting the word out and getting the  vaccine out from johnson johnson to  pfizer to moderna  they're available if you want them but  that's not enough now you need to be  berated by none other than dr  fauci because you're playing politics  that's the reason  you may have not gotten it listen  this is not complicated we're not asking  anybody to make any political statement  one way or another  we're saying try and save your life and  that of your family and that of the  community  it's mind-boggling guys and look at  brian kilmeade even saying  you know some people might not want to  get vaccinated  because they're being encouraged if you  just left them alone is the implication  maybe they would go and get themselves  vaccinated it's like an insanely  childish reverse psychology to get  people vaccinated